yeah okay hello and welcome to this
video playing cm rst 2003 who the heck
is that no name okay so what is he up to
Kings in your group routes of Kings
Indian you had a Petrosian system that's
interesting lines that is somewhat
surprisingly i think seldom plate it's
not not bad at all so let's see if i can
directly play for Queen side expansion
cells b3 here my opponent somehow did
not go form and age 6 early on so that
what what the heck
what to where is the trick there is no
trick okay you just have ruined his
Queen side interesting now an a4 is just
the deadly weakness my plan is okay
thanks I would have done that anyway and
now I'll see fine and this is the
winning position for wide x remarkable
okay so let's not celebrate too early
even though white is winning now after
six he might have f4 so okay I'm going
to play a free and give me that square
on f2 the reason why white is winning
here is the DSC 6v6 pawn takes pawn
takes Bishop takes p5 winning a piece
and there is no recent way for him to to
handle this and as we seen what you
don't even wanted to find out what I
don't know I don't know I get this game
this Bishop see a door something what's
going on that's weird
black realized i was strange yeah that's
kind of the petroleum system is like
cook completely misplays it and it looks
like this we just quite often the case
in the Kings in Ian this is one of those
openings that really am yeah that looks
terrible if it's late played badly and
here we have a couple of things I
actually believe that and black should
start age 60 m to make sure that white
is dropping back here the the thing to
understand is that the setup with bishop
on III luck here and the night on d 2 is
why it's ideal set up against the king
of Indian if you can get this in you're
in perfect shape especially if you have
not cancelled yeah this is the perfect
scenario we should be three nighttime d2
is fantastic if you have not cancelled
this is something that is often
witnessed in this line that t6 is a
mistake and now white gets this in here
why it is I know it sounds harsh almost
winning because he's not moving the King
every just stays iam and he's got be 45
the automatic attack and there's no
counter tech for black because the king
is not even on the Kings side and well
in the game i played this very quickly
so then on h6 i can drop back to e3
getting the scenario and the weird thing
was that he played this move which are
already kind of question like okay let
me play this which is extremely strange
and funny is that after loop b1 the
engine wants to play this when things
black is okay that's really quite
amazing
so funny text again it wants to play
here yeah because in this situation
there are two pieces hanging a bit funny
so that indicates that would be one
maybe one of the best move in this
position and I should castle now yeah
well this is a fantastic for idea the
engine just gives 0.7 which is not
really doing it justice yeah every would
be one Bishop e3 before and it's an
automatic attack on the queenside you
have an eighth one this is just this
just lost I think nothing more nothing
less the queenside is going to fall and
yeah I computer is kind of agreeing yeah
here you can claim c 6-r may be
immediately or I wasn't sure about this
situation yes but ok this is winning
author yeah anyway everybody you have it
really doesn't matter the situation is
so bad on on this side of the border now
I thought you would even it would at
least play the bishop somewhere I mean
it wouldn't help but this was kind of a
wee bit too simple yeah so Kings Indian
Petrosian is one of the lines that like
needs to have some end entered out
otherwise it might happen that she lose
like this ok thanks for watching